pensez-vous du célibat je pense qu'un
célibataire d'abord faut savoir qu'il a
un caractère spécial au sein du jeu je
trouve qu'il vaut mieux se marier quoi
oh moi personnellement je pense que lé
beau être mariée
moi je voudrais jamais mariés je trouve
que l'homme et la femme
ils sont destinés à être à vivre
ensemble moi je peux rien dire parce que
ma cheville marié j'ai passé commande à
toute manière doivent pouvoir se marier
et les choses nécessaires
le célibat moi je trouve ça formidable
et axa pas du tout moi je trouve ça
navrant tout à fait navrant pouvez vous
me citer trois célibataires célèbre
vient il yad'abord mois et puis il ya
mon copain d'ailleurs été de cocteau je
crois sacha distel mais est géniale idée
sacha distel
elvis presley aille à luis mariano il y
a plus mariano chasse n'avoue walter bus
et blanc simon prévost
le rappelle jean jacques rousseau
[Musique]